also ich muss sagen früher konnte ich
gar kein schaf hat mittlerweile magie
schafe hey was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video sollte
ich hoffe natürlich wäre es gut mir auch
danke der nachfrage
ich kann ja eigentlich schon mal direkt
zu haben worum es heute geht und zwar
geht es um james also das sind glaube
ich alle promis worten ich war in zwei
verschiedenen supermärkten mehr habe ich
nicht gefunden und im mit 100 standen
auch nicht mehr deswegen das sind gerade
alle aktuell niemand kaufen kann ich
habe nämlich vor drei tagen das video
rausgehauen ich teste alle fünf minuten
terrine aus dem supermarkt und das ist
eigentlich ganz gut bei euch angekommen
und ich hab in dem video auch gefragt
was ich denn eventuell noch machen soll
also von welchen lebensmitteln kann man
das lebens behindern von welcher art
produkte ich mal so alle testen soll
dies im supermarkt rib und rob kommentar
pringles ich habe früher das einzige was
ich es nach waren diese hier die kenne
ich und hat die original mehr kenne ich
auf jeden fall bis jetzt noch nicht
deswegen macht ihr euch dieses video ich
werde alles probieren
kaffee wird brot sollte man eine
punktzahl von eins bis zehn und eure
aufgabe ist es erstmal den kanal zu
ruinieren jeden tag 19 uhr gibt's im
video und aber auch weitere arten von
produkten die kommentare zu schreiben
nicht aber nächstes mal testen soll also
ich glaube man immer alle dies davon
gibt in einem super mario mally
formatieren zu erläutern dann würde ich
sagen wie lange habe ich lange keine
ahnung warum diese prämie sorte kleiner
ist als die anderen bisher eine
frechheit oder nicht so schlimm alles
gut wächst vielleicht wir starten hier
erhalten uns bis hierhin durch und dann
werden die auch noch mal sortiert je
nach geschmack welcher mir am besten
schmeckt also ich weiß jetzt schon wir
werden hier in der wohnung auf jeden
fall chips für die nächsten
drei monate haben so viel kann man ja
gar nicht erst wie lange halten sich
eigentlich bringen 15-20 jahr gut bis
dahin also das ist produkt nummer eins
ich kenne die also ich probiere jetzt
trotzdem erreicht also gut dass wir
damals angefangen haben die schmecken
mir die habe ich schon mit zehn jahren
gegessen sind auf jeden fall ecke ab
kriegt von mir jetzt mal so um den start
zu haben acht punkte
es ist jetzt nicht so für mich so ein
neues produkt was mich so voll umhaut
ich keine zeit schon und dass ich mich
vernünftig deswegen sind acht punkte
voll in ordnung und wir positionieren
das allgemein will und was ich auch
machen kann
ich nehme einfach ein schiff immer raus
und legt den oben drauf weil da kann man
immer direkt was drin ist und die haben
ja alle in der verschiedene farbe
beziehungsweise ein anderes gewürzt
blöderweise kenne ich die hier auch
schon die haben ja früher in einem
freibad vergessen sour cream mit onion
ich glaube wenn ich alle runter bin mit
schlechten richtigen unterschiedlich
kann man da jetzt nicht erkennen oder
eigentlich nicht mit der begründung dass
sich die auch schon länger kenne früher
oft gegessen habe und sie natürlich ein
bisschen anders schmecken aber trotzdem
gut verteidigt auch ihr ab punkte
das heißt wir haben gleich das ist aber
wirklich fair euch beide kann ich dann
so lange macht er nichts draus
unentschieden ist okay und jetzt kommt's
mir zudem sollten die ich doch nie
wirklich noch nie probiert haben wir das
jetzt braucht oder nicht aber ich bin
mal gespannt vor allem auf dieses ziel
der nazis alles klar prinz zahlt in
pepper diesen halt auch eigentlich
gleich aus da ist halt nur ein bisschen
salz und pfeffer drauf ne-yo nichts
besonderes alles klar
pressath nummer drei
ich finde das schmeckt ein bisschen zu
starten ich möchte auch noch spülmittel
wer am besten schon mal eben wasser
spülmittel geschmeckt hat hier finde ich
nicht so der kater schmeckt nicht also
ganz komisch was mache ich dann jetzt
nicht das hat mich nicht überzeugt da
gibt es von mir auch nur vier von zehn
punkte führen besser besser also
tschuldigung ich muss danach erstmal
schlucken trinken um den geschmack
wieder rauszukommen also die waren geil
die hier nicht mal ganz kurz mal an die
story das muss ich euch einfach mal kurz
erzählen was ihr lasst uns mal hinsetzen
ich habe gestern müllberg gebracht und
habe den müll nicht in unseren müll
rauen transportiert hier gibt es drei
verschiedene oder so sondern in einen
andern weil der hat einfach mehr ist und
ich das immer so machen weil direkt
daneben auch mein auto steht und dann
gucke ich in den briefkasten und ihren
sohn nachbar hat einfach den müll
sortiert und dem ist aufgefallen dass
wir ja gar nicht in seinem haus wohnen
und somit gar keine berechtigung haben
da was reinzutragen halt diese stifte
die nicht mehr wirklich funktionieren
also deswegen ab so weggeschmissen
in meinem briefkasten gelegt warum auch
immer willkommen in deutschland
wobei ich noch mal kurz erzählt dann
habe ich mich erstmal weiter das hier
gibt habe ich schon ein punkt zeit
verteilt vier von zehn mac app store
leid aber das leben geht weiter so als
nächstes haben wir bringen
hawkins beißen also ich muss sagen
früher konnte ich gar kein scharf ab
mittlerweile mag schafe
[Applaus]
hier muss man jetzt aber schon sagen
guck mal das sieht auf jeden fall vom
typ her anders aus okay ich habe mit
vier ersten deswegen ist es ganz schön
feist tipps zu probieren
grün ist nummer vier also für mich ist
das jetzt überhaupt nicht scharf also
hot & spicy ist für mich etwas anderes
schmeckt aber gut aber ich dachte da
kommen wir so eine richtige feier
schärfe weil das sieht ja hier auch so
ausgehen wie schmecken die eigentlich
wie die originale nur in ganz ganz klein
bisschen schärfer
deswegen aber gefällt mir wohl deswegen
gibt es von mir
sieben von zehn punkte also hat mich
jetzt nicht um aber ist auf jeden fall
besser als holland etwa weil das
schmeckt einfach nur nach spülmittel so
um irgendwie schon mal platzierung hier
haben wir noch okay okay wenn ich am
meisten gespannt tortilla chips
denn da jetzt ein abschlussturnier also
wahrscheinlich keinen schuss drin hab
ich dem aufgemacht ach ja irgendwie
schon mal gemacht und dafür braucht dich
heißt ein paar tipps hier raus und ich
dachte gerade so irgendwann ist halt
einem supermarkt gegangen hat sich da
welche raus genommen hätte sein können
aber ich hatte jedoch nicht probiert
dieser chip ist eigentlich die der
singular von chips chip ja na also auch
bei essens chips nun dieser chip sie
ganz anders aus und jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt weil ich bin eigentlich so
käser mache ich sehr gerne
doch schmeckt schon recht käse ich mich
sagt er sich sehr intensiv
ich habe voll geworden als ich glaube
wenn man wenn man davon zehn gegessen
hat dann reicht das auch erstmal weil es
halt so käse schmeckt gut deswegen finde
ich sind hier genau an der richtigen
stelle und bekommen von mir als habe ich
eine pflege und bekommen von mir
9 von 10 punkten also platz eins bis
jetzt denn drei hammer
hat mir nicht klarkommt und beißen jetzt
komme ich ja durcheinander
aber das ist anders sind jetzt genau die
gleichen drin oder haben die einfach nur
die verpackung gewechselt ich glaube
dass er gleich nach ich habe eigentlich
noch bis 6 achtet deswegen kann ich dazu
jetzt gar nichts sagen aber vom namen
her sind die gleichen
deswegen mal schauen hatte marc coma hat
glaube ich nicht wenn man die beiden
jetzt mal vergleicht das ist ja was ganz
anderes oder die sind ja deutlich
gewürzte aus warte mal ich probier's mal
kurs erstmal den hier ja ganz klar
ja und jetzt probiere immer noch schnell
den diesem schärfer ist da bin ich mir
sicher
warum auch immer bin ist mir nur ein
nein wäre hier das willst schreibe es in
die kommentare
mir geht es einfach mal davon aus dass
das unterschiedliche sorten sind es gebe
in den scanner glaube ich eben sieben
punkte
da mir das hier schon fast zu scharf ist
es gibt sechs das heißt wir haben die
genau nebeneinander platziert die waren
ganz schön scharf also auch hier das
obenrum ist doch anders oder wenn ich
schreibe es in die kommentare sondern
ist eigentlich auch scheißegal
als nächstes haben wir classic paprika
und sweet paprika dann gibt es ja gar
nicht mehr soviel ausgefallen ist von
denen also ich hatte eigentlich so auch
sorten gehofft die man so gar nicht
erwartet aber paprika ist ja alles
zweite fahren produktnummer sieben mal
schauen
also es ist ein video da tu ich mich
extrem schwer mit einfach weil das
schmeckt alles in ordnung wir haben
nichts was total eklig ist außer dass
wir es nach spürte hier geschmeckt hat
dieses zeiten pepper aber hier gegen die
punktzahl zu übertragen die irgendwie
zwischen 7 und 9 liegt wollte ich wieder
recht kommen
ich sage einfach mal die skispringer
haben mich immer noch am meisten
überzeugt deswegen gibt es hier
acht von zehn punkte und wir sind auch
schon bei der letzten bringen ist heute
angekommen suite paprika das hier war
gerade classic africa wie viel paprika
hatten wir dann schon vielleicht brauche
ich auch noch mal kurz einen schluck
wasser und meinen geschmack wieder zu
neutralisieren also bei der jugend er
ihn war es viel leichter zu entscheiden
okay das schmeckt mir jetzt gut oder das
schmeckt mir weniger gut
die packung ist ja nicht mal die
situation noch ist als hätte jemand
schon was rausgekommen aber der deckel
war ja noch zu und dann werden die damit
dass hier noch extra portion drin ist
jetzt stimmt ja gar nicht ich habe
mitbekommen dass pringles sogar mal
abgemahnt worden ist weil die mit zu
großen verpackungen werden und da
eigentlich gar nicht so viel drin ist
und hier haben wir jetzt ein gutes
beispiel dafür naja gut also letztes
produkt-suite paprika man kann jetzt
aber schon sehen ich bin immer hier an
zooms dass sie sich alle von der farbe
und auch vom gewürz schon unterscheiden
also außer die drei diesen oder relativ
gleich aus naja gut zwei paprika immer
wieder das gleiche
also es ist so schwierig schmeckt von in
ordnung kommt kriegt auch 8 hinten
tut mir leid dass wir diesmal nichts
dabei hatten was mich sehr überzeugt und
ein produkt was mich gar nicht überzeugt
4 punkte 7 78 88 89
das war's also wenn ihr gerne käse milch
kann ich euch die ihr mir empfehlen
schmeckt lecker
das ist auch voll in ordnung außer
unsere spülmittel variante hier recht
das war es mit dem video wie gesagt
schreibt super gerne weitere
produktarten in die kommentare
ich bin gespannt und nächstes mal wird
dann hoffentlich wieder interessant
haben ich habe mal so an schokopudding
gedacht alle schokoholics von allen
verschiedenen marken dass wir hoffen
aber dass alle leute haut rein da ist
alex w